by now i'm sure you've all heard about
the new iphone 14
and it's basically identical to the
iphone 13 even including the internal
chip
one thing that apple should get credit
for is keeping the prices the same at
least for american customers despite the
record high inflation the same however
cannot be said about european customers
who experienced price hacks across the
board take the iphone 14 pro max for
example in the us this phone comes in at
eleven hundred dollars but in the uk
this phone comes in at 1200 pounds and
in germany this phone comes in at 1 450
euros this translates to 1 385 in the uk
and an eye watering of 1 450 in germany
it wasn't just the pro series that saw
these price bumps either all the
standard iphone models went up by 70
pounds or 100 euros this means that the
average european will need to spend 30
more than an american to get the same
product most people have written this
off as pure greed from apple if apple
had risen prices in the us the media
would have shredded them but by only
increasing prices in europe they've been
able to substantially reduce the
backlash this argument definitely has a
lot of merit to it given that apple
didn't exactly need to raise prices
given their healthy profit margins but
with that being said there is also a
legitimate reason for raising prices
only in europe to put it bluntly
european currencies are currently
performing a cliff-dive maneuver in
comparison to the us dollar the
conversion rate from euros to dollars is
at 20-year lows and this isn't some new
phenomenon either in fact the euro has
been consistently losing dominance to
the dollar since mid-2008 when you could
get 1.60 cents using just one euro today
however you can barely get a single
dollar with a single euro a similar
story can be seen with a pound as well
the pound is currently at a 37 year low
against the dollar and has been on a
consistent decline since late 2007. at
the peak you could get over two dollars
with a single pound but today you can
only get and fifteen cents with a single
pound when you consider these shifts and
currency values apple's price hikes
while still insane make a little bit
more sense but this brings up the
question why in the world are european
currencies doing so bad
taking a look back this is clearly not
the new trend this downtrend has been
forming for well over a decade and the
recent issues have simply worsened the
situation so what set off this chain of
events
well one of the biggest fundamental
issues plaguing the euro since its
creation is the fact that it's not just
representative of one country initially
this was seen as a benefit the euro
promised to unify european countries
economically and to make trade between
these neighboring countries easier than
ever before this unification also
promised to make europe as a whole a
stronger economic force against the us
but the problem with the unified
currency is that it's virtually
impossible to set economic policies that
are appropriate for every member you see
with america while the various states
have differences culturally and
politically they're extremely
homogeneous economically when
californian businesses are suffering
from a bear market so are taxing
businesses similarly when new york
businesses are booming it's more likely
that floridian businesses are also
booming so it makes sense for all these
states to use the same currency and for
the fed to set overarching economic
policies the same however cannot be said
about the members of the eurozone and
especially the poorly performing members
over the past 15 years this has
primarily been spain and degrees greece
basically got wiped out by the 2009
financial crisis if the eu didn't bail
them out greece would have defaulted on
their debt and spiraled into a
depression during the worst of it
reese's budget deficit was equivalent to
12.9 percent of their gdp for
perspective that would be equivalent to
the us having a budget deficit of 2.7
trillion dollars per year at first
greece tried to play it cool and assured
everyone that they would get their debt
in check within two years but just four
months later greece would admit that
they could default at any moment around
the same time spain was going through
their own economic crisis
like greece spain's economy was
devastated by the 2008 financial
recession and they were spiraling into a
depression as an outside observer
americans could feel bad for these
countries and their people but
economically speaking it they weren't
all that affected the same however could
not be said about eurozone countries who
had skin in the game greece and spain
were already massive dead weights
bringing down the euro but if these
countries collapsed oh boy it would be
bad so the prosperous eurozone countries
had no choice but to bail out this
failing economies the eu and the imf
would provide 240 billion euros worth of
emergency funds to greece and 100
billion euro rescue package to spain
and where do you think all this money
came from it of course came from
quantitative easing also known as money
printing since 2008 the euro money
supply has literally doubled to make
things worse the bailouts weren't all
that impactful either sure they helped
these countries stay afloat and did not
default but fundamentally they didn't
change anything and the underlying
economies would just continue to get
worse
while spain and greece were undergoing
economic hell many eu countries like the
uk and germany were actually recovering
extraordinarily well their unemployment
graphs were plummeting and their need
for money printing was dwindling however
they couldn't stop the money printing
because certain eurozone countries like
spain and greece were still very much
feeling the pain
in both spain and degrees unemployment
would rocket to 25 to 30 percent for
perspective unemployment didn't cost 25
even during the worst of the great
depression
so these countries were no longer just
experiencing a financial crisis
they were in a full-fledged economic
depression and this was painfully
evident in their gdp numbers spain's gdp
would fall from a peak of 1.6 trillion
dollars to just under 1.2 trillion
dollars similarly greece's gdp would
fall from a peak of 354 billion dollars
to 192 billion dollars
even today neither of these countries
have been able to return to their peak
gdps and this becomes even worse when
you consider that europe has been
experiencing record inflation meaning
that their inflation-adjusted gdps are
even worse
also while i've mainly been picking on
greece in spain throughout this video
these guys were by no means the only
perpetrators though they were the worst
some of the other countries dragging
down the euro included cyprus portugal
italy slovakia and even france
this left the ecb in an extremely
difficult situation what were they
supposed to do
on one side they have countries like the
uk germany and denmark where
unemployment was reaching historically
low levels these countries indicated
that it was time to chill out on the
money printing and potentially even
start quantitative tightening however on
the other end of the spectrum you had
the perpetrators who were in a more dire
state than ever these countries
indicated that it might even be time to
pump up the money printing the ecb would
end up siding with the countries that
needed help and they would keep economic
policies loose while this was probably a
godsend for the struggling countries the
prosperous countries that weren't
exactly happy and rightfully so the
prosperous countries didn't really
benefit all that much from the loose
economic policies but they were very
much harmed by its accompanying side
effects they were starting to feel that
they bought significantly more to the
table than they were receiving and this
feeling is what would eventually evolve
into brexit in june of 2016 britain
would vote on leaving the eu and after
years of negotiations and discussions
brexit would finally take place on
january 31st 2020. much of england felt
that they had finally gotten a fresh
start and that they were no longer way
down by the eu
but little did they know that pandemic
was just around the corner
starting off with the most obvious
economic side effect of the pandemic we
have the money printing people often
like to criticize the us for their
excessive money printing as they should
but what people often forget is that the
whole world has been printing just as
much money if not even more take the uk
for example who has printed 895 billion
pounds at the average conversion rate
over the past two years this is
equivalent to 1.14 trillion dollars
now the u.s has grown its money supply
by a far larger amount coming in at
roughly 6.2 trillion dollars but you
have to look at it in relative terms
compared to the american gdp of 21
trillion dollars american printing works
out to roughly 30 percent of their gdp
compared to the english gdp of 2.7
trillion dollars however english
printing works out to 42 of their gdp
that's clearly a problem the ecb on the
other hand hasn't been nearly as
aggressive with their money printing but
they've been much more lenient when it
comes to interest rates the ecp
literally maintained a negative interest
rate into 2022 and they're just now
starting to aggressively hike rates
all of that extra relative printing from
the uk and the loose economic policies
from the ecb have to be reflected
somewhere and that somewhere seems to be
conversion rates economic policies
aren't the only battle that europe has
been fighting though they've also been
hit hard by russian sanctions
you see it europe has historically been
extremely dependent on russia for oil
and natural gas given the russian
sanctions europe has been forced to find
new energy partners which has been
anything but easy the problem is that
the entire world knows that europe is
desperate for energy which means that
sellers can charge a premium and that's
exactly what they've been doing gas
prices across the notable european
countries are well above 5 per gallon if
not over six dollars per gallon a
similar story can be seen with
electricity prices as well
main wallet russia is simply adding fuel
to the fire by essentially retaliating
against the sanctions you see europe has
yet to fully cut off russia they still
receive a significant amount of crude
oil through pipelines like the nord
stream 1. this specific pipeline was
closed in july for 10 days for regular
maintenance but when the pipeline was
reopened it was only operating at 20
capacity russia would close down the
pipeline again at the end of august
citing an apparent leak and russia has
yet to reopen this pipeline as of
september 8. while russia would like to
convince us that there's a leak it seems
like russia is simply halting overflow
on purpose to spike energy prices in
europe as europeans are forced to spend
more on our energy they're naturally
gonna pull back on discretionary
spending and given that the central
banks are also starting to pull back
this sets up the perfect storm for an
economic disaster
at the end of the day the euro was
created with good intentions it aimed to
unify europe economically and create a
global powerhouse however a major
shortfall of the system is the vast
inequality between the member countries
this has forced the prosperous countries
to constantly pop up the failing
countries which hasn't been particularly
helpful for either of them the uk has
decided to take this issue into their
own hands and become the first country
to leave the eu
but this hasn't worked out all that well
either the pandemic along with the
russian sanctions have taken a massive
toll on all european countries and most
of them are simply fighting to put off a
nasty recession and bring down inflation
compared to this the us is actually
doing really well we've been ahead of
the curve when it comes to economic
tightening and the recession isn't that
bad at least not yet so naturally the us
dollar has been destroying european
currencies and by the looks of it that's
not going to be changing it anytime soon
so europe better get used to those
iphone price hikes because they're
likely permanent but that's just what i
think what do you think about european
iphone price hacks comment that down
below also drop a like if you hope that
europe can turn things around and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm mari and i'll see you guys on
the next one